where are you at with music right now
because i feel like at this point in
time
you just do what you want so sometimes
we'll we'll get a
a random tape from you mm-hmm well you
know you're you're
hopping on songs that with people who
who you [ __ ] with
um last year we got the ep but like what
do you
how do you feel about i mean by the way
love the fact finally last year we got
cushion or juice on spotify yeah thanks
bro that was a big [ __ ] deal yeah
everybody was [ __ ] with that that's
funny but yeah like
where are you at music wise man are you
still inspired are you still
like like you know how do you feel about
about the rap game right now
i love the way that the rap game is
moving now i think a lot of the
work that i put in and paved the way on
is like paying off not only for me but
for a lot of other people
facts so um you know with that in mind
uh i just i see uh
the next step in my evolution and i'm
always working on it i'm always in the
studio i'm always working with new
artists and things like that but for my
own
personal project the next thing for me
is to just
you know have have another big moment
that is stand out
not just to other people but really
impresses me
and um i know what i want to talk about
and i know what i want the numbers to
look like
and i know what you know type of people
i want to impress
but i can't get there until i actually
recreate the project so that's what i'm
doing is i'm making the sound and i'm
getting the content and everything that
i
really think is gonna you know take me
to the next level in a lot of different
people's opinions as well as mine and um
you know that's working with different
production working with different
writers um
just trying to put together not really
trying but putting together
a full ass project that's gonna be the
evolution of you know who i am in my
career